[Música]
la verdad me dijeron que viniera medio
elegante y por eso estoy así
y yo hago caso a los protocolos de la
charla usted
en primer lugar desearles que estén aquí
en este momento tan maravilloso para mí
aunque no crean estoy nervioso ya me
comí las uñas hasta los pies y siempre
uno vive con este tema de los nervios la
conferencia se llama ría se póngale
hacer algo a esa cara y por eso queremos
en este momento que si nos recibe en un
elemento que es va a ser muy útil
importante durante el periodo del
trabajo que vamos a hacer es un pequeño
elemento que lo vamos a repartir por
favor
nos colabora un compañero repartiendo el
elemento mientras se mientras se hace la
repartición de este elemento
soy alegro logo hay otros que son feliz
yo logos pero digamos que ese es el
rango más alto todavía no alcanzó a ser
feliz el logo apenas estoy en allegro
logo y estoy trabajando sobre la ciencia
de la alegro logía una ciencia bastante
complicada y muy difícil pero aquí voy
voy en esto como quien dice alegro lo es
el bachillerato feliz el logo es como la
universidad
que es feliz que ser feliz la felicidad
es un trabajo al cual todos queremos
llegar pero que es ser feliz todos todos
proponemos de teorías todo el mundo
propone temas sobre la felicidad pero
creo y considero que la felicidad es un
tema importante y hay que llegar el ser
humano a ser feliz pero si no puede ser
feliz por lo menos se alegre y si no sea
no es alegre por lo menos sonría sonría
póngale hacer algo a sacar a uno cuando
va por la calle y ve a alguien de pronto
es una sonrisa si sean fingía una
sonrisa fingida lo alegra uno es yo creo
que eso es lo importante que uno ve en
el ambiente caras maravillosas caras
alegres
nosotros consideramos que como alegro
luego ya puedo darle teorías de la
neurología
la alegría hace parte de la felicidad
entonces la felicidad es el punto máximo
y la alegría es hace parte y busca
llegar a esa felicidad como ven es una
pirámide bastante difícil de llegar da
pero para eso todo el mundo debe ser y
debe buscar la felicidad y que ser feliz
que ser feliz será una etimología de que
la palabra feliz viene de felicitas y
que a su vez es fértil de fecundo cuando
una persona es feliz es fecunda es
fértil es se siente vida en ese ser
humano
y como alegro logo solo insisto mucho
porque esta ciencia que estaban haciendo
hasta ahora quiero que la apoyen por
favor apoyen la alegro lo he a ustedes
que pueden desde sus casas doy la teoría
de que la felicidad se corresponde en
tres partes importantes la alegría la
auto-realización y la actitud ante lo
que no se nos presenta en la vida el
peje la vida el balance hay mucha gente
que pronto nace en un hogar lleno de
cosas maravillosas desde el punto de
vista económico y otros pues que
realmente no tienen nada ese peaje de la
vida es el que tenemos que tener una
actitud ante lo que nos encontremos
cuando empezamos a tener una razón de
ser
encontramos que también estamos metidos
dentro de un concepto económico y eso de
una semana tenemos que tienen una
actitud ante ese eje de la vida pero hay
que diferenciar felicidad de la alegría
la felicidad es muy diferente de la
alegría es muy diferente
la felicidad es una etapa emocional que
permanente en donde se ha luchado por
una autorrealización mientras que la
alegría de por sí es un momento no más
es un instante que corresponde a estar
como en jolgorio como de júbilo hay
muchos casos de la diferencia entre
felicidad mi hijo puede estar en el
mejor equipo de colombia puede estar
jugando el mejor equipo hay felicidad
pero no haya no hay alegría porque él no
hace goles entonces lo entendemos de esa
manera
yo puedo haber sido feliz porque hice
una autorrealización de haber estudiado
la carrera que yo quise pero no soy
feliz o no soy alegre porque estoy
manejando taxi es decir no estoy
complementando lo que yo lo que yo
quería hacer o para el cual me auto
realice para mí la felicidad corresponde
a esto es como una botella la botella de
la felicidad el líquido es la alegría y
el anís el ingrediente principal de esa
botella es el chiste pero hay una tapa
que es la dificultad la dificultad que
tenemos para hacer para lograr la
felicidad esa tapa depende como lo
veamos puede ser una dificultad o no
quiere que nosotros podamos compartir
esta botella con todos muchas veces no
se puede pero esa es ése es el gráfico
lúdico de que corresponde ser la
felicidad para este alegro logo
qué es la felicidad la felicidad es un
estado de paz que sólo se alcanza en la
comunión con dios esta es una teoría
religiosa y otros también aplican otras
teorías pero aquí es el otro elemento de
la felicidad que es la autorrealización
lo consideramos como una satisfacción de
haber alcanzado y cumplido una o más
metas personales planeadas en la medida
en que lo logremos pues seremos felices
sí
por eso yo creo que usted deben hacer un
balance en sus vidas y llegar a la
conclusión luchado por mi
autorrealización he luchado porque como
como se dice la vida está llena de metas
entre más metas mejor
la felicidad es el máximo logro de la
autorrealización se considera eso la
felicidad es el máximo logro de la
tormenta y todo el mundo quiere dar
mensajes de felicidad y todo el mundo
quiere considerarse dueño de la palabra
felicidad algunos dicen el dt las que
más me gusta de las que está nadie dice
eso ya así imagínate con plata
la gente
de verdad hay maravillosas teorías si
les gusto darle carita feliz muchas
gracias
es importante que sepamos que colombia
es el país el segundo país más feliz del
mundo esto es una cosa impresionante no
sé de dónde sacaron esa información de
que somos el país más feliz del mundo
con una aplicación de impuestos por
todos lados con esa seguridad con la
salud vuelta nada pero somos felices qué
lindo somos felices somos un país el
segundo país más feliz del mundo y
estamos también de segundas en
corrupción eso porque pagaron para no
quedar de primeras es una cosa increíble
estamos estamos punteando de verdad esto
es una cosa impresionante pero para ser
feliz
esto vive y aprende piensa y ríe el ríe
para mí es vital es vital porque es a lo
que quiero llegar el río es la base de
la raíz y otros podrán ser felices con
muchas cosas pero para mí que soy
allegro luego el reír es vital y está
basado en algo fundamental que es nada
menos ni más que el chiste
el chiste el chiste es algo maravilloso
en la medida en que encontremos chistes
por todos lados eso es para mí la vida y
de hecho
soy una persona que vive del chiste y
toda la vida hemos considerado que el
chiste es mi herramienta principal y que
es el chiste lo tenemos como una
historia breve narrado dibujada que
encierra un doble sentido una burla o
una idea disparatada y cuya intención es
hacer gracioso o en el final ser alegre
a quien lo oye y por eso existe para mí
es vital
y muchas veces en el colegio cuántas
veces el profesor no dijo en un momento
dado que alguien se reía trabaja jaimito
porque no me hecha el chiste para
reírnos todos sólo escuchamos muchas
veces en los colegios pero la risa hasta
dónde llega ahí tiene que tener un
límite la risa toda esta gente que ven
acá murieron de risa sí señores
murieron de risa como les parece
todos ellos se fueron muertos de la risa
increíble una cosa de estas o sea
tenemos que ponerle un límite a esta
teoría porque si no no podemos que esta
teoría la gente muera no era la
intención la idea es que lleguemos a un
límite hasta donde podemos ser alegres
calcas quilón de esparta zeus y filemón
increíble que haya muerto el que el que
quema el que murió ahí fue uno
en un solos
no me acuerdo bien el nombre de él murió
por un chiste de un burro no sé qué no
era de maduro que está hablando no sino
que el burro el tipo emborrachó el burro
y el burro fue a comer unos hijos
el nombre le causó gracia y ahí fue
donde este tipo murió de la risa claro
que en teoría es mejor morir de la risa
hay mucha gente que ha muerto de otra
cosa hay gente que ha muerto de hipo por
ejemplo si si otra gente murió en el
baño es mejor estar riéndose y no
pujando entonces yo creo que de una otra
manera hay que ser plausibles con que
uno muera de la risa y para qué sirve un
chiste un chiste nos sirve para hacer
alegres para relacionarnos de manera
divertida conocer otras personas conocer
otros temas conocer y conservar un
estado de salud física y mental creo que
de una otra manera
el chiste es vital esa es mi vida el
chiste
yo considero que gracias a dios hay una
virtud de encontrar chiste en todo
momento en cualquier instante entonces
se nos voltea la pirámide y encontramos
que el chiste la base la alegría es el
contenido y el fin el objetivo es la
felicidad ese ese es como el panorama al
cual queremos llegar el chiste como base
de vida
si te gustó por favor me la carita feliz
por favor
escuchemos esto
temo no presentar al autor a lozano
hijuan clima con los años los mismos
creadores de los cinco hermanos los años
presentan
juan ricardo jano
[Música]
para ricardo lozano sufrió una
enfermedad el polio pero sus padres lo
sacaron adelante y lucharon contra la
infelicidad que desempleo la baja estima
la pobreza la tristeza y los problemas
sociales del doctor auto como lo sacaron
adelante no deje de verlos sobre este
capítulo de la vida real
muy pronto sólo en cines
[Música]
para mí el chiste es el prontuario de
una persona el chiste es la biografía de
alguien por medio intermedio del chiste
podemos llegar a conocer una persona
existe de una manera es un acto
literario del cual que se desarrolla una
historia quien no tiene la foto la foto
de bebé en un plato no en una olla esa
vista esa no falla esa foto es
indicadora de que la mamá lo está
cuidando a uno mucho de verdad esa foto
de bebé es maravillosa y la mamá utiliza
esa foto es por área de protección esa
es un área de protección y una manera de
proteger su hijo como cuando uno ya
crece en la primera foto que le muestran
a la novia de uno es la primera foto
dice mire los ahí con sus bolitas al
aire para que la novia diga pero no ha
cambiado nada y ahí es donde uno queda
he protegido realmente donde queda una
protección esa es la idea de esa foto
del plato vemos todas estas cosas de
verdad pero nosotros creo que
esta etapa de la vida lo que tenemos que
llegar es a consejos la gente dice eso
es puro cuento pues unimos las dos
palabras cuenta y consejos entonces
deleitarse con música en nuestro primer
consejo deleitarse con música con buena
música para eso y para la felicidad
tengo este tema
[Música]
camina plácido entre el ruido y la prisa
y piensa en la paz que se puede
encontrar en el silencio
[Música]
un poema maravilloso deshidrata
otros mismos desiderata demás germán un
maravilloso poema que en latín significa
desiderátum que significa cosas deseadas
y las cosas que sea de nosotros son eso
llegar a la felicidad pero para eso
debemos replantearnos la letra
enuncia tu verdad de una manera serena y
clara y escucha a los demás incluso al
torpe ignorante también ellos tienen su
propia historia
[Música]
qué lindo 1
pero no aplica
no aplica
es sencillo analizar dice enuncia tu
verdad de una manera serena y clara uno
no lo puede aplicar de esa manera porque
ese poema fue hecho en otro tiempo y no
aplica mire usted va en la noche a
oscuras y se pega el deutsche quito con
la punta la cama usted no decir
[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué vaina
me he pegado con el dorso de mi dedito
pequeño y el madero hacia el
recubrimiento de la cama no sé si sea
y bota la grosería más grande
capacite por favor capacitarse es
importante en la capacitación pero mire
no no no no se capaciten en sexo de
verdad no del sexo de género como está
en serio hay gente que en el que en el
sexo aplica por ejemplo el a mí
me invitaron una amiga así dijo ven te
invito al xbox el sex box
xbox
ay ahorcamiento patada nudillo patada en
la cosa el primer patrón se me paró las
ganas del amor por el sexo de verdad no
se capaciten en lo que dejen las cosas
como están tranquilos no se afanen por
ser mejores que otros
toca un instrumento hay que tocar el
instrumento ustedes y yo por ejemplo y
sueñen toquen un instrumento y sueñen
esas vidas
yo cumplo toca un instrumento la
guitarra y sueño que estoy con amparo
grisales es bonito es bonito este con
cuenta y consejo tome buenas decisiones
tomar buenas decisiones es esa hora me
remito al tipo que muy humilde tenía una
moneda de 1000 y fue un restaurante con
hambre en el en el letrero decía a mi
sopa oa miles el seco el tipo dijo
para mí que hago
yo quiero las dos cosas pero no puedo me
toca me toca tomar una decisión en el
sello sopa para el sec y tiro la moneda
y le fue entre una alcantarilla por dios
no odies por favor no o bien mire no
odien ay me llegó una carta de una
señora y se me habían dicho que para las
personas que yo odiará les hiciera una
carta y las quemara ya hice lo primero
que hago con las cartas entonces uno no
entiende verdad
teorías de otros países como la en la
china que dice usted oa la persona que
odia escriba en un papel esa persona que
odia y meta ese papel dentro de una
botella y salga a caminar
ójala descalzo por el mar y sienta la
tranquilidad respire profundo y si llega
a ver esa persona metal es un botellazo
entonces uno no entiende de verdad que
eso es la manera eficaz de no odiar no
se tatúe no sintió y respeten se el
cuerpo las personas feas por favor no se
tatúe
una persona linda bueno hágalo hágalo
una persona fea no ve a una persona
tatuarse un irrespeto al cuerpo uno de
respetar el cuerpo por dentro y por
fuera no se tatúen mire una persona fea
tatuada aparece la pared de un baño
público por favor no afecta tu en ese es
un cuento y consejo que nos marca hay
que agradecer la persona que no agradece
un favor pequeño nunca va a agradecer un
favor grande agradezca y me remito al
caso
imagínense 2 de la mañana 2 de la mañana
se oye un grito en puré me empuje me
empuje pero mientras el señor está se
levanta y la señora a dónde va voy a
colaborarle al vecino pero porque hasta
ahora está lloviendo cayendo no importa
voy a hacerlo porque a mí alguna vez me
mareé mi carro y alguien me ayudó lo voy
a hacer voy a agradecer y en ese
aguacero tremendo con la lluvia y todo y
salió el tipo dijo dónde está dónde está
ahora la voz aquí en el columpio en
poder en poder entonces uno entiende que
ese es el acto de agradecimiento hay que
agradecer cuídate mire si usted tiene
un amor cuide lo si tiene dos cuídese
usted
hay que cuidarse hay que cuidarse por
amor de dios hay que cuidarse ora y
respira por favor no sabemos ni respirar
orar orar hay que orar hay que creer en
dios crea en algo crean algo hay que
orar yo creo que este tema es ese sí ese
es importante y de serio porque en el
caso personal creer en dios me ha hecho
maravilloso me ha hecho un hijo de él y
creo que es el que me ha inspirado a
orar ya estar en manos de dios es no
pregunte tonterías uno siempre es
preguntando tonterías una señora
embarazada está embarazada no esto es un
simulacro entonces para qué pregunta
no pregunten a uno le dice mi amor sabes
que es lo más lindo que tú tienes no que
es no sé por eso pregunto que tiene
entonces uno sobre todo en el tema en el
tema del amor que no la pasamos en eso
preguntando tonterías y nuestro otro
consejo que tenemos acá es el último por
favor mil y mil gracias a ustedes para
que ustedes de una u otra manera se
sientan complacidos y muy chévere que
hayan estado con nosotros yo lo bendiga
muchas gracias
bendiciones